and speaking of getting away with
whatever you can get away with
representative Naylor has requested in
conjunction with representative Doug
Collins I believe of Georgia they have
requested that special councilor Muller
appear before the House Judiciary
Committee in a tweet Nagler said this he
said quote today ranking member Collins
called for special counsel Muller to
appear before the House Judiciary I
fully agree special counsel Muller
should come before the committee to
answer questions in public about his 22
month investigation into President Trump
and his associates he said in the next
week he said in order to ask special
counsel Muller the right questions the
committee must receive the special
counsels full report and hear from
attorney general Barr about the report
on May 2nd about that report on May 2nd
we look forward to hearing from mr.
Muller at the appropriate time now a lot
has been a the Muller report and
actually we shouldn't even call it that
at this point we're just going to call
it the bar summary the bar summary of
the Muller report has made has been a
fascinating Expedition of the media
really falling over themselves for the
news cycle and let me unpack that real
quick because no one has seen and I'm
sure David has covered this ad nauseam
right no one has seen the full report
and while I don't personally expect the
full report to defer or depart from the
bar summary significantly there's
clearly damning information in the
report that this administration does not
want to get out otherwise if the report
exonerated him fully like he said it
would have been published in full for
everyone to read item by item by item
that's number one but number two the
reason I mentioned the media is because
it's fascinating how they ran with this
narrative that Trump has been exonerated
and they did so in this enclosed news
cycle of about 48 hours for the
mainstream media and then some of the
other people
some of my friends Michael Tracy Glenn
Greenwald they're still slam dunking
this thing even though they haven't read
the reports themselves you know so it's
just amazing how you know how everyone
has been running to the hills with this
story of Trump being exonerated but
literally no one in Congress and no one
in the media has seen the full report
and for me it just seems like if we're
going to be objective if we're gonna at
least try to pretend as though we are
objective journalists then by week
goodness it gotta read the damn report
that being said I find it fascinating
and I actually think it's it's it's sort
of a good thing that there's a
bipartisan call for Muller to testify
before Congress Naylor is a Democrat I
believe from New York and Collins is a
Republican from the state of Georgia
both of them are calling for mullet to
testify the question is is what will he
be able to say what constraints are
going to be placed on him what could he
and and also what naylor pointed out is
there's no way they can ask the
appropriate questions without getting
access to the full report so it's very
important that they get access to the
full report and again the more I say
that the more ridiculous I think all of
our media outlets are you know CNN MSNBC
all the mainstream media outlets Fox
News of course we expect Fox News to do
what it does but four people four four
people who for months have called for
objectivity not MSNBC you notice I
didn't list them but four other
organizations other mean to organ media
organizations to call for objectivity to
all of a sudden make this an
open-and-shut case shut it down close no
more questions and he's been exonerated
and we've moved on we've moved on from
it because that's the nature of our new
cycle it really screams to me that they
weren't looking so much for objectivity
as much as they were looking for a slam
dunk new cycle four clicks and whether
that meant allowing Donald Trump to tell
America that he has been completely
exonerated without
anyone objective or anyone not a part of
the administration seeing the actual
report if that meant that's what they
had to do to get a good news cycle then
that's exactly what they did it really
is fascinating to me that that we I'm
not surprised but I'm always reminded
that the very people who are calling for
objectivity very quickly side on the
side of power when it benefits them
financially and when it benefits their
new cycle and they can get the ratings
that they want well they'll just throw
everything else to the wind when
literally no one not a single journalist
not a single reporter not a single
commentator not a news agency he'll not
even in the Senate nor the Congress has
seen the report and yet they all have
concluded that they know so well what's
in that report that they can say that
the president has been fully exonerated
well we'll see about that
when it comes time for special counsel
Moeller to testify and that's only if
Congress people are able to be prepared
for that testimony to ask the right
questions by being able to read the
report before Muller testifies today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skills fairs
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years once
again the David Pakman show is giving
you two whole months of access to every
single class offered by Skillshare after
those two months if you want to keep
your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand-new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]